well thank you very much ladies and
gentlemen gentlemen gentlemen a few yes
it was a surprise to me that even even
we sort of when we get in control of new
territory this is also a male territory
but we can get back to that the first
thing I thought about was was actually a
TV serie Boggan it aired a quite a
couple of years ago and it was about the
Danish government choosing a European
Commissioner with the famous tagline
from the movie alien the title was in
Brussels no one can hear you scream the
idea was of course that as in space in
Brussels it's so distance from people's
everyday experience that's nothing you
do really makes a difference
but in my five years in Brussels as a
European Commissioner I think that has
proved all that that this is definitely
not true because Brussels or rather the
European part of our democracy is when
it's working synchronize with business
and national governments and civil
society well then it plays a vital part
of European success I'm looking very
much forward to these new
responsibilities I'm looking forward to
get to know you I'm looking forward to
learn a lot I'm looking forward to with
you I do exactly as what it says on this
conference it's a new decades we have
global ambitions
one of the things I do know though from
previous life is first that space is
endlessly fascinating a second that
whatever is in space is relevant here on
the planet and thirdly it takes money
otherwise nothing's going to happen but
even with the three things in common
there are a number of things that we
need to do in order to have real effects
and this is why it's so important that
you all choose to come together here to
take the effort to use the time because
here we can build the networks that
allows us to provide the conditions and
the support that all the innovative
companies in Europe need to be able to
start to thrive to develop to scale up
to have a global impact and we can
support hugely ambitious projects like
the Galileo satellite system and the
Copernicus Earth Observation program and
we can defend a level playing field in
Europe and across the world and we can
work together to help the European
industry together to innovate because we
have not fulfilled our potential we have
more to do and we can do better and it's
probably true that's no industry but the
space industry holds so much potential
and strategic importance because it is
true about space as it is about the
European democracy that it has a deep
influence in our everyday life and the
satellites
that's obits hundreds or
thousands of kilometres above our heads
they will contribute to our everyday
life in very direct ways and the story
of the european space industry is a
story of success one of the many things
that we can be proud of that we can use
as an encouragement in other industries
as well the european space industry they
produce world-beating products and they
provides thousands and thousands of
valuable jumps it's an industry worth
way more than 50 billion euros it
employs more than 200 thousand people
and yet that of course only scratches
the surface of the importance of the
space industry because even larger parts
of our economy may be up to 10 percent
uses data and services from our systems
in space and Europe's space assets
allows us to act in a strategic and
autonomous way you know of course this a
thousand times better than I do but we
should spread the message so that more
people know and appreciate what we have
achieved together that Galileo can guide
us efficiently and fast from one place
to another that Aetna's provides a
capacity that keeps crews and passengers
saves during landing that Copernicus
supports predictions of climates and
weather patterns and in emergencies like
the terrible terrible fires in Australia
if we can rely on data to show us the
identity of those fires and the effects
on air quality and even that is just a
hint
of the importance that space will have
in the decade ahead because the
technology used in space will play a
vital role in bringing new services to
people here on ground and to help us
fight climate change to make Europe the
first climate neutral continent and this
strategic goal accepts for 2050 we'll
have to use or make the best use of all
the capacities that we have not just
here on the planet obviously also in
space
Copernicus can help us measure pollution
transparently and consistently Galileo
and ignis can help us cut pollution by
showing the most efficient way than
going one place to another or helping
farmers to cut down on the fertilizers
they need or the amount of pesticide to
use this green transition will happen at
the same time as the digital
transformation and the two things of
course poses enormous challenges and
great levels of complexity but also
enormous promises because technology
based in space will help us get the most
out of technology that we have on ground
huge amounts of data coming from
Copernicus well that will provide the
raw material for training artificial
intelligence and enable us to create
best systems and Galileo will help us do
connected cars and supports the Internet
of Things this means that for us in
Europe and for the European space
industry at large there is a huge sets
of opportunity in the decade ahead and
we start from a strong position and this
good news should travel to make
Europeans proud and what we do together
these are some of the bests satellites
makers in the world capturing more than
a third of the world open markets we
have leasing satellites communication
companies thousands of businesses
including startups and small and
medium-sized businesses that uses data
to provide innovative services here on
ground the Copernicus Academy focuses on
research and training to provide the
next generation of researchers and
entrepreneurs with the best skills so it
is indeed a decade of new and valuable
sources in my work as executed
vice-president well part of that is to
make sure that it gets the attention and
the resources to make it happen and
assets
part of that is about money we have to
continue to develop and improve Europe's
space infrastructure like Copernicus
like Galileo and we here we make sure
that there are money to support also new
ideas and new technologies to
technologies in space but also those
technologies that make space use of the
data produced in space and that is why
it is of enormous importance that's the
next seven year budgets makes money
available money that we need for
investments through programs right
horizon Europe and invest a EU the space
program and the digital Europe program
and we also need to do all we can to
help startup and small and medium-sized
businesses throughout Europe to grow and
to compete in world markets because if
you have an excellent service it's not
necessarily the size that's decides if
you can have a global impact or not
with excellent data with excellent
ambition and with the support from this
community you can get also a head start
in world markets and we need to build
that with the support in which space
regulation as well of course as the
Copernicus and Galileo programs offered
to smaller businesses and we need to
help those businesses to find the advice
and the money to turn great ideas into
world-beating
products and Breland ideas of course
we'll have to be able to succeed in the
world where they meet their customers so
that they can build built an industrial
success in the decades ahead and make
new services available that people will
appreciate so we have to support also
the level playing field that allows the
best ideas to come through no matter
where in Europe they come from no matter
how big the company who invented them
and that means having effective
competition in Europe and it means
giving ourselves the tools that we need
to make that foreign state ownership and
subsidies do not deny European
businesses a fair chance to compete on
world markets in all of this work we
need to be on a constant lookout for
ways to bring our different policies
together to achieve something that is
more than the different parts and that
brings me to a second part of the
strategic European industry that of
defence there's a whole lot of ways that
we can get more for our money by making
links between the face defence and space
industry not of course by militarizing
space but maybe to recognize that the
two industries well they share some of
the same challenges and some of the
needs that they have
they may be tackled in similar ways
emerging technologies are changing our
working methods in areas like cyber
defense and artificial intelligence and
in this digital age the same technology
increasingly have both military and
civilian purposes we have seen obviously
how satellite navigation can help armies
operate just as well as it enable people
to find the fastest routes to where they
want to go shopping we have seen all the
technologies back in the days originally
developed for military purposes such as
lasers or microwaves well they were
Boost now everyday appliances on earth
as well as in space our Galileo properly
regulates its services well they provide
intelligence that can be used for both
civilian and defense authorities some of
the challenges and threats well they are
shared too like the risk of interference
collusion with space debris
something that will threaten both
commercial and military satellites we
can work together between European
institutions national governments and
civil and military operators to make the
most of our capabilities the way that we
are doing with the EU satellite
communication initiative the Gov SATCOM
and we can make sure that the data we
collect well that we produce better
services that enhance all of our lives
and of course in that respects make the
best of the defence funds to finance
space research or capability development
because there's no such thing as out
there it is right here it is not
something far removed from our daily
concerns it is right here
space technology is an essential part of
our lives and this is exactly the best
argument to ask taxpayers to fund it
this is not something out there this is
critical for our everyday life and for
our security and I think this is
important equally important for each and
every one of us and I hope with all the
potential and all the achievements
represented in this room that we can be
a common team to achieve this together
to have the funds for the investments
needed to make the best of the data
achieved but also to promote what we
have achieved because Europeans need to
know what we can achieve when we do it
together and I think what you have
achieved in the satellite programs with
the specific benefits on this planet is
one of the things that travel so easily
between people because of these three
basic issues that space is indefinitely
fascinating that what is in space work
here and everyone knows that if you want
to achieve something you really need to
fund it thank you
[Applause]